The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'm Ernst Frankel.
I'll be teaching
next two lectures.
I'd like to encourage you to
contact me outside of class
if you have any questions,
if you want to meet.
And also, please, during
class, ask questions.
It's a somewhat impersonal
setting with the video cameras
and the amphitheater, but
hopefully we can overcome that.
This unit is going to focus
on moving across scales
in computational
biology, looking
from computational
issues that deal
with the fundamentals of protein
structure at the atomic level
to the level of protein-protein
interactions between pairs
of molecules, protein
DNA interactions
and small molecules,
and then ultimately
into protein network.
So we've got a lot
of ground to cover,
but I think we'll be able do it.
As you've seen in the syllabus,
the first couple of lectures
are really a detailed
look at protein structure,
molecular level
analysis, and then we'll
move into some of these
other levels of higher
order, including protein
DNA interactions and gene
regulatory networks.
I think may of you are probably
familiar with this quote,
that "nothing in
biology makes sense
except in the light
of evolution."
And I'd like to offer a
modified version of that, which
is little in biology make sense
except in light of structure,
protein structure,
DNA structure.
We've, of course, seen this very
early on in molecular biology
when the structure of DNA was
solved, and immediately became
clear why it was the
basis for heredity.
But protein structures have been
even more lasting impact time
and time again, many,
many more events,
which have really
revolutionized the understanding
of particular
biological problems.
So one example that was
stunning at the time
had to do with the most
frequently mutated protein
in cancer.
This is the p53 gene.
It's mutated in about
half of all cancers,
and what was observed
early on-- this
was in the days before
genomic sequencing
when it was actually
very expensive and hard
to identify mutations in tumors.
So they focused on
this particular gene,
and they observed that
the mutations clustered.
So this is the structure of
the gene from the n-terminus--
the protein from the
n-terminus and the c-terminus,
and the bars indicate the
frequency of mutations.
And you can see that they're
all clustered pretty much
in the center of this molecule.
Now, why is that?
It was enigmatic until the
structure was solved here
at MIT by Carl Pabo
and his post-doc
at the time, Nikola Pavletich,
and they showed, actually,
that these correspond
to critical domains.
And in a second
paper, they actually
showed why the mutations occur
in those particular locations.
So if you look at the
plot on the upper left,
here's the protein
sequence; above it,
the frequency of
mutations; below it,
the secondary
structure elements.
And you'll see that
mutations occur
in regions that don't have any
regular secondary structure
and can occur
frequently in regions
with secondary
structure or not all
in regions with
secondary structure.
So the mere fact that there's
a secondary structure element
does not define why
there're mutations.
But when the
three-dimensional structure
was solved in the
complex with DNA,
over here on the right--
this is the protein
structure on the left, the
DNA structure on the right,
and in yellow are some of
these highly mutated residues.
It turns out that all of the
frequently mutated residues
are ones that occur at
the protein DNA interface.
All right, so in
a single picture,
we now understand
what was an enigma
for years and years and years.
Why are the mutations so
particularly clustered
in this protein in
non obvious ways?
Since that is the interface
between the protein
and the DNA, these
mutations upset
the transcriptional regulation
through the action of p53.
So if we want to understand
protein structure in order
to understand protein
function, where
are we going to get
these structures from?
So the statistics on how
proteins themselves-- I
show here.
This is from the-- I'll call it
the PDB, the Protein Database.
Its full name is the
RCSB Protein Database,
but it's usually
just called the PDB.
And here, it shows that,
at the time of this slide,
around 80,000
structures have been
determined by x-ray
crystallography.
The next most frequent method
was NMR, Nuclear Magnetic
Resonance, which identified
about 10,000 structures,
and all the other
techniques produce
very, very few
structures, hundreds
of structures rather
than thousands.
So how do these techniques work?
Well, they don't magically
give you a structure.
Right?
They give you information that
you have to use computationally
to derive the structure.
Here's a schematic
of how structures
are solved by x-ray
crystallography.
One has to actually grow
a crystal of the protein
or the protein and
other molecules
that you're interested
in studying.
These are not giant
crystals like quarts.
They're even smaller
than table salt.
They're usually barely
visible with the naked eye,
and they're very unstable.
They have to be kept in
solution or, often, frozen,
and you should a very
high powered x-ray
beam through them.
Now, most of the x-rays are--
what are they going to do?
They're going to pass right
through because x-rays interact
very weakly with matter.
But a few of the x-rays
will be diffracted,
and from that weak
diffraction pattern,
you can actually deduce
where the electrons were
that scattered the x-rays
as they hit the crystal.
And so this is a
picture, the lower right,
of electron density cloud in
light blue with the protein
structures snaking
through it, and what
you can calculate,
after a lot of work,
from these crystallographic
diffraction
patterns is the location
of the electron density.
And then there's a
computational challenge
to try to figure out the
location of the atoms that
would have given rise
to that electron density
that then, when hit with
x-rays, would have given rise
to the x-ray
diffraction pattern.
So it's actually an
iterative process
where one arrives at the initial
structure and then calculates,
from that structure,
where the electrons would
be, from the
position of electrons
where the diffraction pattern
would be when the x-rays hit
it, and determines how well
that predicted diffraction
pattern agrees with the
actual diffraction pattern,
and then continuously iterates.
And so this is obviously a
highly computational problem
because you not
only have to find
positions that are maximally
consistent with the observed
diffraction pattern, but also
positions that are actually
consistent with physics.
So if we have a piece
of a molecule here,
we can't just put
our atoms anywhere.
They need to be positioned
with well defined distances
for the bonds, the
bond angles, and so on.
So it's a highly coupled
problem that we have to solve,
and we'll look at some of
the techniques that underlie
these approaches, although
we'll look specifically
at how to solve x-ray
crystal structures.
I mentioned the second
most common technique
is nuclear magnetic
resonance, and this
is a technology that does
not require the crystals,
but requires a very
high concentration
of soluble protein, which
presents its own problems.
And the information
that you get out
of a nuclear magnetic
resonance structure
is not the electron
density locations,
but it's actually
a set of distances
that tell you the relative
distance between two
atoms, usually protons,
in the structure,
and that's what's represented
by these yellow lines here.
And once again, we've got a
hard computational problem
where we need to figure out a
structure of the protein that's
consistent with all
the physical forces
and also puts particular
protons at particular distances
from each other.
So we talk about solving
crystal structures,
solving NMR
structures, because it
is the solution to a
very, very complicated
computational challenge.
So these techniques
that we're going
to look at, while
not specifically
for the solution of
crystal and NMR structures,
underlie those technologies.
What we're going to
focus on is actually
perhaps an even more
complicated problem,
the de novo discovery
of protein structures.
So if I start off
with a sequence,
can I actually
tell you something
important and accurate
about the structure?
Now, there's a nice
summary in a book called
Structural Bioinformatics
that really
deals with a lot of the issues
around computational biology
is relates to structure,
that highlights many
of the differences between the
kinds of algorithms we've been
looking at up until now in
this course and the kinds
of approaches that
we need to take
in our understanding
of protein structure.
So the first and
most fundamental
obvious thing is
that we're dealing
with three-dimensional
structures,
so we're moving away from the
simple linear representations
of the data and
dealing with more
complicated
three-dimensional problems.
And therefore, we encounter
all sorts of new problems.
We no longer a
discrete search space.
We have a continuous
search space,
and we'll look at
algorithms that
try to reduce that continuous
search space back down
to a discrete one to make
it a simpler problem.
But perhaps most
fundamentally, the difference
is that now we have to bring
in a lot of physical knowledge
to underlie our algorithms.
It's not enough to solve this
as a complete abstraction
from the physics,
but we actually
have to deal with the physics
in the heart of the algorithms.
And we'll look at the
issues highlighted
in red in the rest of this talk.
Another thing that's
going to emerge
is that it would
be nice if there
was a simple mapping of
protein sequence to structures,
and if that were the
case, you'd imagine
that two proteins that are
very different in sequence
would have different structures.
But in fact, that's
not the case.
You can have two proteins
that have almost no sequence
similarity at all but adopt
the same three-dimensional
structure, so clearly, it's an
extremely complicated problem
made more complicated
by the fact
that we don't know
all the structures.
It's not like we're
selecting from a discrete set
of known structures to figure
out what our new molecule is.
We have, in potential,
infinite number
of confirmations and protein
chains we need to deal with.
OK, so I hope that you've had a
chance to look at the material
that I've posted online for
review of protein structure.
If you haven't, please do so.
It'll be very helpful
in understanding
the next few lectures,
and I'll assume
that you're familiar with
the basic elements, protein
structure, what
alpha helices are,
what beta sheets are, primary
structure, secondary structure,
and so on.
And I'll also encourage
you to become familiar
with amino acids.
It's very hard to understand
anything in protein structure
without having some knowledge
of what the amino acids are.
The textbook has
a nice figure that
summarizes the many overlapping
ways to describe the features
in amino acids, so please
familiarize yourself with that.
So these are resources
that we posted online.
Also, the Protein
Databank, the RCSB,
has fantastic resources
online for beginning
to understand protein
structure, so I
encourage you to look
at their website.
In particular, in
their website, they
have tools that you can
download to visualize protein
structures, and
that's going to be
a critical component of
understanding these algorithms,
to actually understand what
these structures look like.
I've highlighted, too,
that I find particularly
easy to use PyMOL
and Swiss PDB Viewer.
You can not only
look at structures
with these techniques, you
can actually modify them.
You can do homology modeling.
So before we get into algorithms
for understanding protein
structure, we need
to understand how
protein structures
are represented.
I've already mentioned that
there are these repeating units
that I'd like you already
know about-- alpha helices,
beta sheets.
We won't go into
those in any detail.
But the two more
quantitative ways
of describing protein
structure have
to do with a
three-dimensional coordinates,
the XYZ coordinates
of every atom,
and internal
coordinates, and we'll
go through those a
little bit of detail.
So again, this PDB
website has a lot
of great resources
for understanding
what these
coordinates look like.
They have a good description
of what's called a PDB file,
and those PDB files look
like this at the outset.
They have what is now called
metadata, but at the time
was just information about
how the protein structure was
solved.
So it'll tell you what organism
the protein comes from,
where it was actually
synthesized if it wasn't
purified from that organism, but
if it was made recombinantly,
details like that, details about
how the crystal structure was
determined.
The sequence-- most of
this won't concern us,
but what will concern us is
this bottom section shown here
in more detail.
So let's just look at what
each of these lines represents.
The lines that contain
information about the atomic
coordinates all begin
with the word ATOM,
and then there's a
index number that
just is referenced for
each line of the file,
tells you what kind of atom it
is, what chain in the protein
it is, and the residue number.
So here, it's starting
with residue 100.
The sequence here
can be arbitrary
and may not relate to the
sequence of the protein
as it appears in
SWISS-PROT or Gen Bank.
And then the next
three columns are
the ones that are
most important to us,
so these are the XYZ
coordinates of the atom.
So to identify the
position of any molecule
in three-dimensional
space, obviously you
need three coordinates,
and so those
are what those three
coordinates are.
And they're followed by these
two other numbers, which
actually are very interesting
numbers because they tell us
something about how certain
we are that the molecule is
really-- the atom is really at
that position in the crystal
structure.
So the first of these
is the occupancy.
In a crystal structure,
we're actually
getting the information
about thousands and thousands
of molecules that are in the
repeating units of the crystal,
and it's possible
that there could
be some variation in the
structure between one
unit of the crystal
and the next.
So you could have a side
chain that, in one crystal,
is over here and in
the next crystal--
a repeating unit of the
crystals over there.
If there are discrete
confirmations,
then you imagine that the
signal will be reduced,
and you'll actually
get some superposition
of all the possible
confirmations.
So number one here
means that there
seems to be one
predominate confirmation.
But if there is more than one,
and their discrete-- if they're
continuous, it'll
just look like noise.
It'll be hard to
determine the coordinates.
But if they're
discrete positions,
then you might find, for
example, an occupancy of 0.5
and then another line
with the other position
with an occupancy of 0.5.
So that's when there's
discrete locations where
these atoms are located.
The B factor's called
the thermal factor,
and it tells you how
much thermal motion there
was in the crystal
at that position.
Now, what does that mean?
If we think about a
crystal structure,
there'll be some parts of
it that are rock solid.
In the center, it's
highly constrained.
The dense core of the
protein, not too much
is going to be changing.
But on the surface
of the protein,
there can be residues
that are highly flexible.
And so as those are being
knocked around in the crystal,
they are scattering the x-rays
in slightly different ways.
But they're not in
discrete confirmations,
so we're not going to see
multiple independent positions.
We'll just see some
average positions.
And that kind of noise can
be accounted for with these B
factors, where high numbers
represent highly mobile parts
of the structure,
and low numbers
represent very stable ones.
A very low number here
would be, say, a 20.
These numbers of 80--
typically, things like that
occur at the ends
of molecules where
there is a lot of
structural flexibility.
So we have this one
way of describing
the structure of a protein where
we specify the XYZ coordinates
of every one of these atoms,
and we'd have these other two
parameters to represent thermal
motion and static disorder.
Now, are those coordinates
uniquely defined?
If I have this
structure, is there
exactly one way to write
down the XYZ coordinates?
Hands?
How many people say yes?
How many people say no?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: You can rotate it.
PROFESSOR: You can rotate it.
You set the origin.
Right?
So there's no unique
way of defining it,
and that'll come up again later.
OK, now, this is
a very precise way
of describing the
three-dimensional coordinates
in protein, but it's not a very
concise way of representing it.
Now, why is that?
Well, as the static
model represents,
there are certain parts
of protein structures
that are really not going
to change very much.
The lengths of the
bonds change very little
in protein structures.
The angles, the tetrahedrally
coordinated carbon,
doesn't suddenly
become flat, planar.
These things happen very-- there
may be very small deformations.
So if I had to specify the XYZ
coordinates of this carbon,
I really don't have
too many degrees
of freedom for where
the other carbon can be.
It has to lie in a sphere
at a certain distance.
So instead of representing
XYZ coordinates of every atom,
I can use internal coordinates.
So here in this slide,
we have amino acids--
the amino nitrogen,
the carbonyl carbon.
So this is a single amino acid.
Here's the peptide bond
that goes to the next one.
And as this diagram
indicates, the bond
between the carbonyl
carbon of one amino acid
and the amide nitrogen
of the next one
is planar, so that angle
isn't even rotating.
So that's one degree of freedom
that we've completely removed.
The angles that rotate in the
backbone or called phi and psi;
phi over here,
and psi over here.
So those are two
degrees of freedom
that determine how
this amino acid is--
the confirmation
of this amino acid.
So instead of specifying
all the coordinates,
I can specify the
backbone simply
by giving two numbers to every
amino acid, the phi and psi
angles, with the
assumption that the omega
angle, this peptide
backbone, remains constant.
And similarly for
the side chains,
and we'll go into this
in more detail later,
we can then give the
coordinates, the rotation,
of rotatable bonds
in the side chain
and not specify every
atom as we go out.
OK, so we've got these two
different ways of representing
protein structure, and we'll
see that they're both used.
Any questions on this?
Great.
OK, so if we're looking
at protein structures,
one question we want
to ask is how do we
compare two protein
structures to each other?
So I already mentioned
that proteins
can have similar
structure, whether or not
they are highly
similar in sequence.
So if I have two proteins that
are highly homologous, that
do have a high level of sequence
similarity-- for example,
these two orthologs,
this one from cow
and this one from rat--
you can see, at a distance,
they both have very
similar structures.
They also have 74%
sequence similarity,
so that's not surprising.
But you can get proteins
that have very low sequence
similarity.
They're still
evolutionary related,
like these orthologs, two
different species that
have the same protein, or
paralogs, a single species that
have two similar copies,
but non identical copies,
in the same protein that
maintain the same structure
when they only have about 20%
to 30% sequence similarity.
And you can get even more
distant relationships.
So here are two
proteins, both in
human, evolutionarily related,
but only 4% sequence identity.
And yet at a distance,
they look almost identical.
And those are evolutionary
related proteins,
but we can also have things
that are called analogs, which
have no evolutionary
relationship,
no obvious sequence
similarity, and yet adopt
almost identical
protein structures.
So this adds to the complexity
of the biological problems
that we're going
to try to solve.
All right, so how
do I quantitatively
compare two protein structures?
So the common
measurement is something
called RMSD, Root
Mean Square Deviation,
and here, I have a
set of structures
that were solved by NMR.
And you can see that there's
a core of the structure that's
well determined
and then there are
pieces of the structure
that are poorly determined.
There weren't enough
constraints to define them.
And these proteins
have all been aligned,
so the XYZ coordinates have
been rotated and translated
to give maximal agreement.
And what's the
agreement measure?
It's this Root Mean
Square Deviation.
So I need to define pairs of
atoms in my two structures.
If it's, in this case, the same
structure, that's really easy.
Every atom has a match
in this structure that
was solved with
the same molecule.
But if we're dealing with
two homologous proteins,
then that becomes a
little bit more tricky.
We need to define which amino
acids are going to match up.
We can also define whether we
care about changes in the side
chains, or whether we only care
about changes in the backbone,
whether we're going
to worry about
whether the protons in
the right places or not.
And you'll see that
these alignments can
be done with either only
heavy chain, heavy atoms,
meaning excluding the hydrogens,
or only main chain atoms,
meaning excluding the
side chains completely.
But once we've defined the
pairs of corresponding atoms,
then we're going to take the
difference in the distance
squared, sum of the
squares of the distances
between the corresponding
atoms and their x-coordinate,
their y-coordinate, and
they're z-coordinate.
Take the square
root of that sum,
and that's going to give us
the Root Mean Square Deviation.
And of course, we have to
minimize that Root Mean Square
Deviation with these
rigid body rotations
to account for the fact
that I could have my PDB
file with the
origin of this atom.
Or I could have my PDB file
with the origin of that atom,
and so on.
OK.
Any questions so far?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do we consider every
single atom in the molecule?
PROFESSOR: So we have a choice.
The question was do we
consider every single atom
in the molecule?
We don't have to do,
and it depends, really,
on the problem that
we're trying to solve.
So if we're looking for
whether two proteins have
the same fold, we might not
care about the side chains.
We might restrict ourselves
to main chain atoms.
But if we're trying to
decide whether two crystal
structures are in good
agreement with each other,
or say, as we'll
see a few minutes,
we're going to try to predict
the structure protein,
and we have the experimentally
determined structure
of the same protein,
and we want to decide
whether those two
agree, in that case,
we might actually
want to make sure
that every single atom
is in the right position.
So it'll depend on the question
that we're trying to answer.
Good question.
Any other questions?
OK.
All right, so so
far, I've shown a lot
of static pictures of molecules.
I do want to stress
that molecules actually
move around a lot, so I'll
just show a little movie here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK, so that
was, in part, an excuse
to play a little New
Age music in class,
but more fundamentally,
it was to remind you
that, despite the
fact that we're
going to show you a lot of
static pictures of proteins,
they're actually
extremely dynamic.
And they have well
defined structures,
but they may have more than
one well defined structure,
especially those molecules
that are doing work.
They're actually
moving things along.
They have multiple structures.
And so when we consider
the protein structure,
it's an approximation,
and we're always
going to mean the protein
structures, not singular one.
OK, so what determines
the protein structure?
Well, I've told
you it's physics.
Fundamentally, it's
a physical problem,
so the optimal protein structure
has to be an energetic minimum.
There has to be no net
force acting on the protein.
The force is negative derivative
of the potential energy,
so that derivative has to be 0.
So we have to have a minimum
of protein structure.
Now, that doesn't mean that
there's exactly one minimum.
Those proteins that had multiple
confirmations in that movie
obviously had multiple minima
that they could adopt depending
on other circumstances,
but there
has to be at least
a local minimum.
So if we knew this U, this
potential energy function,
and we could take
the derivative of it,
we could identify the protein
structure or the protein
structures by simply
identifying the minima
in that potential
energy function.
Now, would that life
were so simple, right?
But we will see that there are
ways of parameterizing the U
and using it to optimize
the structure so it finds
this, at least local, minimum.
And we're going
to look primarily
at two different ways of
describing the potential energy
function.
One of them, we're going to look
at the problem like a physicist
one, and the other
way, we're going
to look at it as a
statistician would.
So the physicist wants to
describe, as you might imagine,
the physical forces that
underlie the protein structure,
and so as much as
possible, we're
going to try to
write down equations
that represent those forces.
Now, we're not
always going to be
able to do that because
a lot of forces involved
are quantum mechanical.
The mere fact the
two solid objects
don't pass through each other is
because of exclusion principles
that deal with
quantum mechanics.
We're not going to write down
quantum mechanical equations
for every atom in our
protein structure,
but we will write down equations
that approximate those.
And wherever
possible, we're going
to try to tie the
terms in our equations
into something
identifiable in physics,
and a very good example of this
approach is the CHARMM program.
And these approaches
actually were the ones
that won the Nobel Prize in
chemistry this past year.
At the other end of the spectrum
are the statistical approaches.
Here, we don't really care
what the underlying physical
properties are.
We want equations that
capture what we see in nature.
Now, often, these two
approaches will align very well.
There'll be some approximations
that the physicist makes
to capture a fundamental
physical force.
That's simply the best way to
describe what you see nature,
and so those two terms may look
indistinguishable in the CHARMM
version or my favorite
statistical approach, which
is Rosetta.
So we'll see that some
terms in these functions
agree between
CHARMM and Rosetta.
Well, there'll be places
where they fundamentally
disagree on how to describe
the molecular potential energy
function because one is trying
to describe the physical forces
and the other one is trying to
describe the statistical ones.
Do we have any native speakers
of German in the audience?
AUDIENCE: I'm a speaker.
PROFESSOR: You want to
read the joke for us?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Institute for Quantum
Physics, and it says
"You can find yourself
here or here."
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: All right,
so for the video,
it's the Institute
for Quantum Mechanics.
And you go to a map at MIT,
and it'll say, you find,
"You are here."
Right?
But in the Institute for
Quantum Mechanics, it says
"You're either here or here."
So that's the
physicist approach.
We really do have to think
about those quantum mechanical
features, whereas on
the right-hand side
is the statisticians approach.
It says "Data don't
make any sense.
We'll have to resort
to statistics."
OK?
So the statistician
can get pretty far
without understanding the
underlying physical forces.
All right, so let's look
at this physicist approach
first, so we're going to break
down the potential energy
function into bonded terms
and non-bonded terms.
So the bonded terms,
as they sound,
are going to be atoms that
are close to each other
in the bonded structures, so
certainly these two atoms,
because they're connected
by a single bond,
are going to be bonded terms.
But we'll see groups of three
or four atoms near each other
will also be bonded terms.
And the non-bonded
terms will be when
I have another molecule that
comes close, but isn't directly
connected.
What are the physical
forces between these two ?
So these bonded terms
then first break down
into a lot of sub terms.
I'll show you the
functional forms here.
We'll just look at a
few of them in detail
and then give you a sense
of what the other ones are.
So this first one
is the bonded term
that describes, actually, the
distance between two bonded
atoms.
Now, again, this
is fundamentally
quantum mechanical
property, but it
would be too
computationally expensive
to describe the
quantum mechanics
and not really necessary because
you can do pretty well by just
describing this
as a stiff spring.
So that's what this quadratic
form of the equation
represents.
So we simply define
b naught here
as the equilibrium
position between these two
atoms, particular types.
There would be two tetrahedral
coordinated carbons,
and that would be
determined by looking
at a lot of very,
very high resolution
structures in small
molecule crystals
so we know what the typical
distance for this bond is.
We get that as a parameter.
There would be a big file
in the CHARMM program
that lists all those parameters
for every one of these bonded
terms, and then if there's
a small deviation from that,
because the molecules
stretched a bit
in your refinement
process, there
would be a penalty to
pull it back in just
like a spring pulls it back in.
Now, it turns out that
when you go this route,
you have to actually come
up with a lot of equations
to maintain the geometry
because, again, we're
going to have to not only worry
about these distance bonds,
but we need to
worry about angles.
So we've got the angle between
this bond and this bond.
What keeps that in place?
So we need to add another
term that's a second term here
to make the angle
between these fixed,
and then we have
to deal with what
are called dihedral angles
to make sure that these four
atoms lie in the
allowed geometry.
And so each one of
these terms accounts
for something like that.
This last term over
here makes sure
that the phi and psi angles
are consistent with what
we see in quantum mechanics as
corrected for any deviations
that we see in these
small molecules
so a lot of terms with a lot
of parameters they're trying
to capture the best description
of what we observe in each one
is motivated by
the fact that there
is some quantum mechanical
principle underlying it.
So-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is
the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I actually don't
know the answer to that.
But there's a reference
there that I'm
sure will give you the answer.
OK, now what about
these non-bonded terms?
So non-bonded terms
of the set are
molecules that are distant from
each other in the structure
of the protein, but
close to each other
in three-dimensional space.
And there are two
fundamental forces here.
The first one is called the
Leonard Jones potential,
and the second one of
the electrostatic one.
And the Leonard Jones potential
itself has these two terms.
One is an R6 term, a negative
r to the 6th dependency.
The other one is
positive nr to the 12th.
The negative r to the 6th
is an attractive potential.
That's why it's
negative, and it's
because of small
induced dipoles that
occur in the electron clouds
of each of these atoms that
pull the molecules together.
And the 1 over r to
the 6th dependency
has to do with the physics
of two dipoles interacting.
The r over 12 term
is an approximation
to a quantum mechanical force.
So the reason the two molecules
don't pass through each other,
as we said already, is because
quantum mechanical forces.
That would be very
expensive to compute,
so we come up with a term
that's easy to compute.
And of course, an
r 12 term is simply
the square of an
r to the 6th term,
so if you already computed 1
over r to the 6th between two
atoms, you just square that, and
you get 1 over r to the 12th.
So it's very
computationally efficient,
and you adjust the
parameters, these r mins,
so that it works out so that
these things agree reasonably
well with the
crystal structures.
And these are crystal
structures of small molecules
that we know in great detail.
And then the
electrostatics is what
you might expect
for electrostatics.
It's got a potential that
varies as 1 over the distance,
and as the product
of those charges,
these can be full charges or
they can be partial charges.
And there's a term
here, this epsilon,
which is the dielectric
constant, and that represents
the fact that, in vacuum,
there'd be much greater
force pulling two
oppositely charged molecules
together than in water because
the water's going to shield.
And so these
electrostatic terms,
this dihedral dielectric
potential term,
can vary from one, which is
vacuum, to, say, 80 for water.
And setting that
is a bit of an art.
OK, so what do these
potentials look like?
Those are shown here.
This is the, in dark lines,
the sum of the van der Waals
potential.
It consists of that
attractive term,
which has the r
over 6 dependency,
and the repulsive term
with the r over 12.
And why does it go up so
high at short distances?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right,
because you can't
have molecules that overlap.
You'll see that
there's a minimum,
so there's an optimal
distance barring
any other forces
between two atoms.
So that's roughly what
these hard sphere distances
represent in the scale models.
And then the
electrostatic potential
also, obviously,
has attractive term,
but it's going to
blow up as you get
to small values,
increasingly favorable.
And so the net sum of
those two is shown here,
the combination of van der
Waals and electrostatics.
It, again, has a strong
minimum but becomes
highly positive as you
get to close distances.
OK, any questions
on these forces?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do the van der
Waals equal the Leonard Jones
potential?
Or is that something else?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
typically, those two terms
are used interchangeably.
Yeah.
Other questions?
OK.
All right, so that's
how the physicist
would describe the
potential energy function.
Rosetta, as I told
you, is an example
of the statistical approach.
It rejects all this
sharp definition
of trying to compute exactly
the right distance between two
atoms by having a stiff
spring between them
and says let's just fix
a lot of these angles.
So we're going to fix the
distance between two atoms.
There's no point
in having them vary
by tiny, tiny fractions
in the bond length.
We're going to fix a
tetrahedral coordination
of our tetrahedral carbons.
We're not going to let them
deform because that never
would happen in
reality, and so we're
going to focus our
search over the space
entirely over the
rotatable bonds.
So remember, how
many rotatable bonds
did we have in the backbone?
We had two, right?
We had the phi and
the psi angles,
and then the side
chains then will
have rotatable bonds
over the side chains.
So in this example,
this is a cysteine.
Here's the backbone.
Here's the sulfur.
And we have exactly one
rotatable bond of interest
because we don't really care
where the hydrogen is located.
So we've got this chi 1 angle.
If there were more
atoms out here,
this would be called
chi 2 and chi 3.
And these can rotate, but
they don't rotate freely.
We don't observe, in
crystal structures,
every possible rotation
of these angles,
and that's what this plot
on the left represents.
For this side chain, there's
a chi 1, a chi 2, and a chi 3,
and the dark regions represent
the observed confirmations
over many, many
crystal structures.
And you can see it's
highly non uniform.
Now why is that?
I see people with
their hands trying
to figure it out in the back.
So why is that?
Figure that's what
you guys are doing.
If not, it's very
interesting sign language.
So if we look down one of
these tetrahedral carbon-carbon
bonds, we have apparently
a free rotation.
But in fact, some
these confirmations,
we're going to have a
lot of steric clashes
between the atoms on one carbon
and the atoms on the other,
and so this is not a
favorable confirmation.
The favorable
confirmation is offset,
and that propagates throughout
all the chains in the protein.
So there'll be certain angles
that are highly preferred,
and other ones that are not.
These highly preferred
angles are called rotamers,
and so we'll use the term a lot.
It stands for
rotational isomers.
And so now, we've turned
our continuous problem
of figuring out what the
optimal angle is for this chi 1
rotation into a discrete
problem where maybe there
are only two or three possible
options for that rotation.
And so now, we
can decide is this
better than this
one or this one?
Questions on rotamers
or any of this?
Excellent.
OK, so how do we determine--
we've decided then
we're going to
describe the protein
entirely by these
internal coordinates--
the phi, the psi, the backbone,
the chi angles of the side
chain.
We still need a potential
energy function, right?
That hasn't told us how to
find the optimal settings,
and we're going to try to
avoid the approach of CHARMM,
where we actually look
at quantum mechanics
to decide what
all the terms are.
So how do they actually
go about doing this?
Well, they take a number of high
resolution crystal structures,
and they characterize
certain properties
in those crystal structures.
For example, they
might characterize
how often a certain
aliphatic carbon-- how often
aliphatic carbons are
near amide nitrogens,
and they might
measure the distance--
they do measure the distance
between these amide nitrogens
and aliphatic carbons across
all the crystal structures
and determine how often
those distances occur.
And you can actually turn
those observations, then,
into a potential energy
function by simply
using Boltzmann's equation.
So we can figure
out how frequently
we get certain
distances on the x-axis
is distance, on the y-axis is
frequency, number of entries
in the crystal structure,
and then by Boltzmann's Law,
we can compute the
density of states
over some reference, which is
actually very hard to define.
And you can look at some
of the references referred
to in the slides to figure out
how currently that's defined,
but we have to find some
arbitrary reference state
to figure out the probability
of being any one of these states
is going to be a function,
a logarithmic function,
of the frequency
of those states.
All right, so we've got an
energy term that's determined
solely by the
observations of distances,
that doesn't say I know that
this one's charge and this one
isn't.
It just says here's
an oxygen attached
to a carbon with double bonds.
Here's a carbon that's not.
How often are they at
any particular distance?
And we go through lots and
lots of other properties,
and we'll go into detail now
to what those other terms are
to look through high
resolution crystal structures,
see what certain
properties are, turn those
into potential energy
functions that we can then
use to identify the optimum
rotations for the side
chain and the backbone.
Oh, and I should also point
out that when we do this,
we'll have different terms
for different things.
We'll have a term for distances
between different kinds
of atoms.
We'll have terms for some
of these other pieces
of potential energy that we'll
describe in subsequent slides,
and we're going
to need to decide
how to weight all of those,
all those independent terms,
to get them to give
us reasonable protein
structures when we're done.
And that, once again, is
a curve fitting exercise,
finding the numbers
that best fit the data
without any guiding physical
principle underneath it.
So you'll be using PyRosetta.
And in PyRosetta,
you'll see the terms
on the board for
the potential energy
functions, the
different features
of the potential
energy function,
and I'll step you
through a few of these
just so you know
what you're using.
There'll also be files
in PyRosetta installation
that will give you the
relative weights for each
of these terms.
OK, so these first
are the van der Waals,
and here, the shape of the curve
looks just like we saw before.
It has to, in some
sense because they're
trying to solve the
same physical problem,
but the motivation
is very different.
There's no attempt to
decide that it should be a 1
over r to the 6th because of
dipole-dipole interactions.
And simply, how do I find
the function that accurately
represents what I
see in the database?
So again, computed, this is
the fa attractive and the fa
repulsive, and
those are determined
based on the
statistics of what's
observed in the
crystal structures.
This one, the hbond, breaks down
into backbone and side chain,
long range and short range.
And the goal of the
hbonds-- so hydrogen bonds
are one of the principal
determinants of protein
structure, and you'll see
that in the reading materials
that are posted online.
And one of the critical
things about a hydrogen bond
is that it needs to
be nearly planar.
So the line between-- the
angle between this atom,
which has the hydrogen
attached, and this one, which
is the free electron
pair, has to be
as close to linear as possible.
And the more it
deviates from linear,
the weaker the
hydrogen bond will be.
And so this hydrogen
bonding potential
has terms that describe the
distance between the atoms that
are donating and
accepting the hydrogen
as well as the
angle between them,
and it's been parameterized
to represent, separately,
things that are far from each
other, close to each other,
things that are side
chain, or main chain.
And here's where it's
really the statistician
against the physicist.
Why divide up side
chain and main chain?
There's no physical principle
that drives you to do that.
It's simply because that's what
gives the best fit to the data,
so the statistician is not
afraid to add terms that
make their models
better fit reality,
even if they don't represent any
fundamental physical principle.
And we'll see it gets
even more dramatic
with some these other terms.
So this is the
Ramachandran plot,
which you'll also
see in your reading.
It represents the
observed frequencies
of phi and the psi angles.
And as you know that there
are only a couple positions
on this phi and psi plot
that are frequently observed,
representing the different
regular secondary structures
primarily, alpha helix and
beta sheet is indicated.
And rather than trying to
capture the fact that protein
should form alpha
helices by having
really good forces all
around, they simply
prefer angles that are observed
in the Ramachandran plot.
So we're going to give a
potential energy function
that's going to penalize you
if your phi and psi ends up
over here, and reward you
in one of these positions.
So from the physicist,
this is cheating,
and for the statistician,
it makes perfect sense.
Shouldn't laugh at that.
OK, and this same will be
true for the row numbers.
So we said that,
for the side chains,
there are certain angles
that we prefer over others
because that's what we
observe in the database.
Again, we're not going
to try to get them
by making sure that there's
repulsion between these two
atoms when they're eclipsed.
We're going to get
there simply by saying
the potential energy
is lower when you're
in one of these
staggered confirmations
than you're one of the
eclipse confirmations.
OK, now, the place
where the difference
between the statistician and
the physicist is most dramatic
comes when we look at
the salvation terms.
So a lot of what goes on
in protein structure--
determines protein
structure, I should say,
is the interaction of
the protein with water.
It's bathed in a bath of
55 molar water molecules,
highly polar.
They normally are hydrogen
bonding with each other.
When the protein sits
in there, the protein
has to start hydrogen
bonding with them.
And where do we find
hydrophobic residues
in a protein structure,
with your hands?
Outside or inside?
Inside, right?
So the hydrophobic residue's
all going to be buried inside.
Why is that?
Well, it's actually
really, really hard
to describe in terms
of fundamental physical
principles.
In fact, it's really hard to
describe the structure of water
by fundamental
physical principles.
Simulations that try
to get water to freeze
were only successful
a few years ago.
So we've tried to
simulate water using
basic physical principles.
It's very hard to
get it to form ice
when you lower the
temperature, so it's
going to be even harder,
then, to represent
how a complicated protein
structure immersed in the water
actually interacts with
those water molecules.
So you've got all these
water molecules interacting
with polar residues
or non-polar residues.
The physicist really
struggles to represent those.
And just to show
you why that is,
let me show you,
again, a little movie.
Unfortunately, no new
age music with this one.
I apologize.
So what's shown here
is a sphere immersed
in a bunch of water molecules.
The red is the oxygen.
The little white parts
are the hydrogens.
You can see them
wiggling around.
And what's the fundamental
feature that you observe?
All right, they're
forming almost a cage
around this
hydrophobic molecule.
Why is that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's hard
for them to interact
with a non-polar residue.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
it's hard for them
to interact with a
non-polar residue.
So the water molecules
want to minimize
their potential energy.
They're going to
do that by forming
hydrogen bonds with something.
In bulk solvent, they form it
with other water molecules.
Here, they can't form any
hydrogen bonds with a sphere,
so they have to dance to
this complicated dance
to try to form hydrogen
bonds with each other
with this thing stuck
in middle of them.
And this is, at its heart,
the fundamental driving force
between the hydrophobic
effect, that
which causes the hydrophobic
residues to be buried inside
of the protein.
Very, very hard, as
I said, to simulate
using fundamental
physical forces.
So what does the
statistician do?
The statistician has a mixture
of experimental observation
and statistics at
their benefit, so we
can measure how hydrophobic
any molecule is.
We can take carbons and drop
them to non-polar solvents,
into polar solvents, and
determine what fraction of time
a molecule will spend
in a polar environment
versus a non-polar
environment, and from that,
get a free energy for
the transfer of any atom
from a hydrophobic environment
to a hydrophilic environment.
That can give us is delta
G Ref, shown over here.
OK, now, in a
protein, that molecule
is not fully solvent exposed
even when it's on the surface,
because water molecules
trying to come
at it from this direction
can't get to it,
from this direction
can't get to it.
So the transfer
energy for this carbon
to go from fully solvent
exposed to buried
is different from
the isolated carbon.
And so the statistician
says, OK, I'll
come up with a function
to describe that.
I will describe what
else is near this atom
in the rest of the
protein structure.
That's what the term
on the right does.
It's a sum over all
other neighboring atoms
and describes the volume
of the neighboring group.
Is the thing next to it
really big or really small?
Usually not described,
necessarily,
at the level of atoms.
It might be side
chains depending
on which program is doing it.
But I have some measure of
the volume of the neighbors.
If that volume is really
large, then this thing
is already in a
hydrophobic environment
even when it's taking
water because it's
surrounded by bulky things.
If the neighbors
are small, then it's
a more hydrophilic environment
when it's taking in water,
and that's going to
modulate this free energy.
Is this function clear?
OK, so by combining this
observation from small molecule
transfer experiments
and these observations
based on the structure
of the protein,
we can get an approximation
for the hydrophobic effect.
How expensive is it
to have this piece
of the protein in solvent
versus in the hydrophobic core?
And again, we never had to
do any quantum mechanical
calculations.
We never had to actually
explicitly compute
the interaction of this
molecule with solvent.
We don't need any
water in the structure.
It's simply the geometry
of the protein that's
going to give us a good
approximation to the energy
function.
All right, so you can look
through all the details
of these online in the
Rosetta documentation
that we provided to get
a better sense of what
all these functions
are, but you can
see there are a lot of terms.
It's increasingly incremental.
You find something
wrong with your models.
You add a term to try
to account for that.
Again, not driven necessarily
by the physical forces.
OK, so what have we seen so far?
We've seen the
motivation for this unit,
to begin with
protein structures,
that the protein
structure really
helps us understand the
biological molecules that we're
looking at.
These structures are going to
influence our understanding
of all biology, so we need
to be good at predicting
these protein structures
or solving them
when we have experimental data.
The computational
methods that we're
going to use--
we're going to focus
on solving protein structures
de novo, predicting them,
but those same
techniques are going
to underlie the
methods that are used
to solve x-ray
crystallography in an MR.
And fundamentally then, we
have these two approaches
to describing the
potential energy.
That's the statistician and
the physicist's approach.
And remember, the
key simplifications
of the statistician are that
we used a fixed geometry.
We're not trying to
figure out the XYZ
coordinates of every atom.
We're simply trying to
figure out the bond angles.
We're going to use
rotamers, so we're
going to turn our
continuous choices often
into discrete ones.
And we're going to derive
statistical potentials
to present the potential
energy, which may or may not
have a clear physical basis.
All right, so let's start with
a little thought experiment
as we try to get into some of
these prediction algorithms.
So I have a sequence.
It's about, I don't know,
100 amino acids long,
and here are two
protein structures.
One is predominantly
alpha helical.
One is predominantly beta sheet.
How could I tell-- this is
not a rhetorical question.
I want you to think for second.
How could I tell whether
the sequence prefers
the structure on the top or
the structure on the bottom?
So we have, actually, a
lot of the tools in place.
Yes, in the back.
AUDIENCE: Can you, based on
previously known sequences,
know which sequence is
predominant in which
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, so
the answer was we
could look at previously
known sequences.
We can look for homology,
and that's actually
going to be a very
powerful tool.
So if there is a homologue in
the database that is closely
related to this protein, and
it has a known structure,
then problem solved.
What if there isn't?
What's my next step?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What if you
start with a description
of the secondary structure,
say the helices and the sheet,
and you counted how often a
particular amino acid showed up
in each of those structures?
Could you then compute
maybe a likelihood
across a stretch of amino acids?
PROFESSOR: Great.
So that answer was
what if I looked
at these alpha helices
and beta sheets
and computed how often
certain amino acids occur
in alpha helices
versus beta sheets,
and then I looked in
my protein structure
and checked whether I have
the right amino acids that
are more favorable than
alpha helices or beta sheets.
And we'll see that's an approach
that's been used successfully.
That's secondary
structure prediction.
OK, other ideas.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: So if you have the
position of the 3D structure,
you can feed your sequence
through the structure
and then put it through
your energy function,
see which one is the
lower [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
So another thing I can do is, if
I have these two structures, I
have their precise
three-dimensional structures,
I could try to put my
sequence onto that structure,
actually put the right
side chains for my sequence
into that backbone confirmation.
And then what would I do?
I would actually measure
the potential energy
of the protein in top structure
and the potential energy
of the protein in
the bottom structure.
If the potential
energy is higher,
is that the favorable structure
or the unfavorable structure?
Favorable?
Unfavorable?
Right, it's the unfavorable.
So I want the lower
free energy structure.
OK, so let's think
about-- that's correct,
and that's where we're headed.
But what are going to be
some of the complexities
of that approach?
So first of all, what
about these side chains?
I have to now take a
backbone structure that
had some other amino
acid sequence on it,
and I have to put these
new side chains on.
Right?
If I put those on in the
wrong way-- let's say,
this is the true one--
let's say one of these
is the true structure.
Let's begin with
a simplification.
All right, so let's say your
fiendish labmate has actually
solved the structure
of your protein,
but refuses tell you
what the answer is.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And she actually
has solved two structures,
neither one of which she's going
to give you the sequence to.
But she's giving you the
coordinates for both of them.
They're the same length.
And so she asks you,
ha, you took 791.
You can figure this out.
Tell me whether that
your sequence is actually
in this structure
or that structure.
She says one of them
is exactly right.
You just don't know which one.
OK, so she gives you the
backbone coordinates,
so you go.
You put your amino
acid sequence, say,
with Swiss [? PDB. ?] You add to
the backbone all the right side
chains.
But now, you have to
make a bunch of decisions
for these side
chain confirmations.
If you make the wrong
decision, what happens?
Well, you stick this atom close
to where some other atom is.
Now, you've got an
optimization problem, right?
You believe that one
of these backbone
coordinates is
correct, but you've
got a very highly coupled
optimization problem.
You need to figure out the right
rotations for every single side
chain on this protein, and
you can't do it one by one.
You can't take a greedy approach
because if I put this side
chain here, and I put this
side chain here, they collide,
but if this was wrong and
supposed to be over there,
then maybe this is the
right conformation.
So I have a coupled
problem, so it turns out
to be computationally
expensive thing to compute.
So we're going to look at
what to do if we know backbone
confirmation, but we don't know
the side chain confirmation.
We can try to solve that
optimization problem,
and you'll actually do
that in your problem set.
Now, what if the
backbone confirmation
isn't exactly correct?
So let's say you do what
was first suggested,
and you search the
sequence database.
You take this sequence, and
you find that it actually
has two homologs, two
things with similar sequence
similarity.
There are two proteins
with 20% sequence identity
that have completely
different structures.
This one has 20%
sequence identity,
and this one has 20%
sequence identity.
So you have no way of deciding
which one's which, right?
And neither one is going to be
the right protein structure.
So you know that by putting the
side chains onto these protein
structures, you do have to solve
those problems with side chain
optimization, but what,
obviously, is the other thing
that you're going to
need to have to solve?
All right, you're going to
need to solve the backbone
optimization problem, and
this becomes even more
coupled because when
I move this backbone,
then the side
chains move with it.
So now, I've got a very,
very complicated optimization
problem to deal with.
The search space is enormous,
and even if I discretize it,
it's still very, very large.
In fact, there's
something famous
called the Levinthal Paradox.
Of course, Cy
Levinthal, who was once
upon a time a professor here
and then moved to Columbia--
he did a back of the
envelope calculation
for extremely simple models
of protein structure.
If you imagine the proteins
were to randomly search over
all possible confirmations
with very rapid switching
between possible
confirmations, it
would take basically
the lifetime
of the universe for a
protein to ever fold.
So proteins don't
do random searches
over all possible confirmations,
and they can check out
confirmations
incredibly rapidly.
So we certainly can't
do that, so we'll
look at the
optimization techniques.
All right, so we discussed
how to use energy optimization
functions to try to decide
which one's correct,
and that even if the
structure is the correct one,
we have the side chain
optimization problem.
If the structure's the incorrect
one, we've got two problems.
We've got the backbone
confirmation and the side
chain.
This is frequently called
fold recognition or threading.
This choice of, you've
got a protein structure.
You want to decide if
your sequence matches
this one or that one.
There are a couple
of other problems
that we're going to look at.
So this was already raised by
one of the students, the idea
that we try to predict
the secondary structure
of this protein, so we'll
look at secondary structure
prediction algorithms.
This was a very early area
of computational effort
in structural
biology, and we'll see
that the early methods
are remarkably good.
We can look for
domain structures,
and this is really
a sequence problem.
So we can look
through our sequences,
and rather than looking for
sequence identity or similarity
with known
structures, we can see
whether there are
certain patterns,
like the hidden
Markov models that you
looked at in a
previous lecture, that
can allow us to recognize the
domain structure of a protein
even without an identical
sequence in the database.
So we won't go over that
kind of analysis anymore,
and then we'll
spend a good amount
of time looking at ways of
solving novel structures.
So if you don't have a
fiendish friend who solved
your structure for you,
and there is no homologue
in the database,
all is not lost.
You actually can now predict
novel structures of proteins
simply from the sequence.
All right, so a little
history as to the prediction
of protein structure.
It really starts
with Linus Pauling,
who went on to win the
Nobel Prize for this work.
And this is in the era-- this
paper was published in 1951.
This was what computers
looked like in 1951,
and that thing probably
has a lot less computing
power than your iPhone
or your Android.
So Linus Pauling did
not solve the structure
of the alpha helix, predict
that alpha helices existed,
using computers.
He actually did it
entirely with paper models.
And in fact, he solved this--
he got the key insights
for the alpha helix when
he was lying sick in bed.
That's a very productive sick
leave, you might imagine.
He was using paper
models, but it
wasn't all done
while lying in bed.
So he and others,
the field as a whole,
have spend a lot of time
observing small molecule
distances, so they
have some idea what
to expect in protein structures.
They didn't know the
three-dimensional structure,
but they knew a lot
of the parameters
about how far apart things were.
And they also knew
that hydrogen bonds
were going to be extremely
favorable in protein
structures.
And so he looked for
a repeating structure
that would maximize the
number of hydrogen bonds
that occur within the
protein backbone chain.
And he knew, also, the
backbone-- that the amide bonds
would be planar and so on.
So there were a lot of
principle that underlay this,
but it was really
a tour de force
of just thinking
rather than computing.
Another really important
contribution early on
was made by Ramachandran,
was at Madras University,
and his insight had
to do with the fact
that not all backbone
confirmations were
equally favorable.
So remember, we have
these two rotatable bonds
in the backbone.
We have the phi angle
and the psi angle.
And this plot
shows that there'll
be certain confirmations
of phi and psi angles
that are observed within
these dashed lines,
and then the other
confirmations, which are almost
never observed.
Now, how did he figure that out?
Once again, it wasn't
with computation.
It was simply with paper
models and figuring out
what the distances would be, and
then carefully reasoning over
those possible structures.
So you can get very far in
this field, initially, back
then, by simple hard thought.
OK, so with these
two observations,
we knew that there
were going to be
certain kinds of regular
secondary structure
and that not all
backbone confirmations
were equally favorable.
OK, but now, we want to advance
actually predicting structures
of particular proteins, not just
saying that proteins in general
will contain alpha helices.
So how do we go
about doing that?
So the first
advances here, we're
trying to predict the
structure of alpha helices,
and this paper in
the 1960s introduced
the concept of a helical wheel.
Now, the idea here,
if you'll imagine
that this eraser
is an alpha helix,
I'm going to look down the
backbone of the alpha helix.
And I'll see that
the side chains
emerge at regular positions.
There's going to be
100 degree rotation
between each sequential
residue in the backbone
as it goes around helix.
It's going to be displaced
and rotated by 100 degrees,
and I could plot,
on a piece of paper,
the helical projection,
which is shown here.
So here's the first amino acid.
100 degrees later, the second.
100 degrees later, the third.
And I can ask whether the
residues on that backbone
have a sequence that
puts all the hydrophobics
and hydrophilics on the
same side, as in this case,
or on different sides.
Now, what difference
does it make?
Well, if I have an
alpha helix that's
lying on the surface
of a protein,
this could have one side
that's solvent exposed and one
side that's protected.
So we would expect that some
of these alpha helices lying
on the service would
be amphipathic.
Half of them would be
hydrophobic, hydrophobic,
and half of them
would be hydrophilic.
And purely, as someone
suggested from the pattern
of the amino acids, and here the
hydrophobicity of the pattern
of the amino acids, we could
make reasonable predictions
of whether this protein forms a
particular kind of alpha helix,
an amphipathic alpha helix.
Now, is that going to help
us for all alpha helices?
Obviously not, because I
can have alpha helices that
are totally solvent
exposed, and I
can have alpha helices
that are totally protected.
So this pattern will occur in
some alpha helices, but not
all.
So another idea
that was raised here
and was used early
on with great success
was to actually figure out
whether certain amino acids
have a particular alpha
helical propensity.
Do they occur more
frequently in alpha helices?
At the time, it was
also thought maybe
you could find propensities
for beta sheets
and other structures.
So compute the statistics
over for every amino acid,
shown as a row here.
How often is it observed
in the database?
How often does it
occur in alpha helix?
And how often does it occur
in beta sheet or in a coil?
And from these, then, we
would compute probabilities
and compute using, perhaps,
Bayesian statistics to compute
the poster
expectation for having
a certain sequence
in alpha helix.
They didn't quite use
Bayesian statistics here.
They came up with a
rather ad hoc approach,
and when you read
it in hindsight,
it seems kind of crazy.
But actually, you
have to remember
when this was being done.
This is being done before a
big influence of mathematicians
into structural biology.
This is 1974, and they used
more physical reasoning.
They knew something
about how alpha helices
formed from chemistry.
They knew that,
typically, there's
nucleation event, where a small
piece of helix forms initially,
and then that extends.
They knew that there
were these propensities
for certain amino acids
to form alpha helices,
and other amino acids, which
tended to break the helix.
And they came up with
an ad hoc algorithm
that counted how often
you had strong helix
formers, how often you breakers.
You can see all the
details in the references.
The amazing thing is, with this
very ad hoc thing and a very,
very small database
of protein structures,
you could look at the
total number of residues
that they're looking at
over all the structures,
there's 2,473 and
residues, not structures.
And now, we have
many, many more times
than that of
structures of proteins.
Even with that,
in 1974, they were
able to achieve 60%
accuracy in predicting
the secondary
structure of proteins,
so it's really an
astounding accomplishment.
And to put that in
perspective, there
was an evaluation of a whole
bunch of secondary structure
prediction algorithms
done about a decade ago,
and things haven't changed
that much since then, where
between 1974 and
2003, almost 30 years,
they went from 60%
accuracy to 76% accuracy.
OK, well, that's not
bad, but it's not a lot
for-- you'd expect
maybe over 30 years,
you could do a lot better.
So the simple approach
really captured
the fundamentals of predicting
secondary structure.
There's a lot of work
that's been done since,
and I encourage you to
look in the textbook
if you're interested, to look
at all the newer algorithms that
have tried to solve the
secondary structure prediction
problem.
OK.
All right, so secondary
structure prediction, then--
you can look in the textbook
for the modern methods,
but the fundamental ideas were
laid down by Chou and Fasman
in the 1974 paper.
We're already said that looking
at the kinds of approaches
that we discussed
earlier in the course
can help you solve
domain structures.
I would like to focus on,
at the end of this lecture
and the beginning-- and the next
lecture about how to actually
solve novel structures from
purely amino acid sequence,
and we're going to
go back to the idea
that there is a potential
energy function.
We now have both the CHARMM
approach and the Rosetta
approach to protein
structure, and so there
is some protein
folding landscape.
There's an energy function.
If you have different
conformations,
you'll be at different
positions in landscape,
and we'd like to
figure out how to go
from some starting confirmation
that may be arbitrary and find
our way to the minimum
energy structure.
All right, so there are going
to be three fundamental things
that we'll talk about
in the next lecture.
We're going to talk about
energy minimization,
how to use these potential
energy functions that we
started off with to go
from approximate structures
to the refined structure.
That's the thought
problem I gave you.
You have the structure, but
you have the wrong side chains.
Could you minimize them?
And so that's making
small changes.
We'll discuss
molecular dynamics,
which actually tries to simulate
all the forces on a protein
and to actually carry
out a physical simulation
of the process.
That's the CHARMM
approach, and we'll
see some interesting
variants on that.
And then we'll look at
simulated annealing, which
is an optimization technique
that's actually quite broad,
but can be applied
here, to search
over large, large
conformational spaces,
much further than a protein
would actually evolve
in a molecular dynamic
simulation that's
simulating protein function.
You allow the protein, now,
to jump between confirmations
that have no real
potential to transfer
between in a normal room
temperature in water,
but can be done, obviously,
easily in the computer.
So I'll stop here.
Any questions before we close?